10 años del humo blanco argentino el 13
de marzo de 2013 después de la
controversial dimisión de Benedicto 16
el cardenal Jorge Mario bergoglio fue
elegido como santo padre de la Iglesia
Católica Francisco nombre que eligió
vergoglio para su papado es el primer
sumo pontífice latinoamericano y jesuita
en la historia de la institución
hermanos y hermanas los dejo por ahora
pero muchas gracias por su bienvenida
por favor recen por mí
fregaste permee el Papa Francisco ha
sido uno de los jerarcas católicos que
más ha salido del Vaticano ha realizado
40 viajes a 60 países diferentes
privilegiando naciones en situaciones
complicadas Palestina Jordania cuba El
Congo y Sudán del sur han sido algunos
territorios visitados por el santo padre
su santidad nombre con el que reconocen
al papa los feligreses ha sido sumamente
vocal con su deseo de trabajar por la
transformación social del mundo
los reportes por violencia sexual contra
Menores en la iglesia católica también
han sido abordados por el argentino
desde escuelas católicas irlandesas
hasta conventos portugueses los
escándalos sexuales de la Iglesia
Católica han indignado al mundo en
Irlanda una investigación reveló que en
el lapso de 1920 a 1990 más de 9000
menores murieron en residencias
administradas por la iglesia católica el
reporte indica que 2000 de ellos
sufrieron abusos sexuales en 2021 una
serie de reportes desvelaron que más de
200.000 niños han sido Víctimas de abuso
sexual por miembros del clero francés en
Lisboa una comisión de investigación
independiente requerida por el Vaticano
señaló que al menos
4,815 menores fueron Víctimas de abuso
sexual por sacerdotes portugueses al
menos 100 de los acusados siguen libres
y en funciones
facho un sentido
algún sentido llamado a una lucha sin
cuartel contra los abusos a menores
tanto sexuales como en otros ámbitos por
parte de todas las autoridades y
personas Pues estamos ante crímenes
abominables que deben ser borrados de la
faz de la tierra
que van a cancelarte y da la facha de la
tierra a sus 86 años el Papa Francisco
se ha ganado el corazón de millones por
su activismo político y lucha por
reformar la iglesia católica